the first thing I should do is I should
probably clean up by setting out for
something which sort of flirted over
before but didn't talk about in much
detail which is that suppose we have
some function right and it's let's go to
it okay
so we said that the one of the
conventions for how to write the
primitive or lowercase F is to write it
as capital F good okay
now just to revise right we know that
one function only has one derivative
okay but it's got a bunch of different
primitives a whole family of them okay
so we distinguish between them why I
need a cluster do you remember that note
slowly I mean if this is ringing a bell
yes okay good now I forgot to mention
that I was a bit annoying you had a
close that one right remember we called
this an arbitrary constant you have to
say yeah because it really can be
anything like its value could be
anything that's what we mean by
arbitrary you have to sustain well okay
what kind of number is it right so
really you should say off on the side
here and it's a bit like um you know a
general solution way like okay sine x is
equal to 1/2 and I said what can this
revise what is the general solution
please remember sign yeah okay good n PI
plus switching switching yeah good times
in this case what is it
okay thank you right and because you've
introduced your end right that's why we
had to say here
well the K M has to be an integer yes
just be a little more the same way it's
always say okay so like likely I've had
and he would describe what rules in
different days can you do the same thing
for C okay so every time you find the
primitive you don't have to do the
weekly brackets but the alternative is
you're saying we're okay because you're
gonna say this is true where I prefer
curly brackets and they're fun to draw
anyway so no it just they just take some
practice okay so see we tend to say it's
a real number
okay well you guys have three into
students so we're gonna go with because
I'm later on when we do move on to the
special iwork only regarding nor for
reasons that are hard to explain unless
extension to so that's where the later
okay now here's what I'm trying to do
I'm try to evaluate the cluster right so
at the moment it can be any number which
is why I've got this whole family of
graphs that all equally could claim to
be the primitive okay so what I need to
do I'm working out well okay what's the
number points right so if I can know
like the difference between all these is
the the part that it traces out the
points that it goes through so so if I
know that this primitive goes through a
set point like say this one
yeah and I give you its coordinates
suppose it passes through five members
at one one two well it doesn't look like
one one to me just to be interesting
let's go because that's all yeah that's
all right he's got a point that's not
doesn't look at five anymore let's make
it seven okay so now that I know it goes
through a point right it could be all
these other ones it must be this one and
this one only okay so that can I can use
that back to evaluate what the customers
so here's the way I would do it you can
do that later you can do it later all
right thank you suppose let's rewrite
this by the way I might not write it
like that I might say this is do you
wanna be X okay which would make this
for y so how do I evaluate what the
custom is well I say when this is what
the coordinate to seven means right
when x equals 2 y equals seven
yes so I'm going to take that now I'm
gonna pop it into this line y equals x
squared plus C right so that's gonna
give me seven equals 2 squared plus my
constant so you get four there three so
now I have my equation for y it's not an
arbitrary constant anymore I've
evaluated that's all yeah well it
depends on what they give you the
question in in what terms they give it
to you isn't it so if they gave it to
you in just F okay just F so they might
say something like find f of X where how
would they say they would say where f
dash x equals 2x and instead of giving
you coordinates because there's no X&Y
this X in this F they would say F of
what I have to
seven so that's that's the equivalent of
saying it passes through two comma seven
okay and then you would go about it in
the same way you'd work out exactly the
same constant okay but it's important
you can't see this step you cannot leave
out the constant or like say okay I can
tell what the constant is right away
you've got to pop it in say it's some
arbitrary thing and then evaluate a
properly this is these steps here right
they're quite important later on it
won't just be a number when you're doing
like something who's on it actually
signifiers later on when it's like wait
to change or exponential growth in decay
this will mean like a population or some
level of radiation or a temperature or
something like that okay so even though
it's just a number in our case it'll
become really important later it's like
I'll just skip this step okay